[Music]
the reason that small dogs bark more
than large dogs I mean I don't think
it's been scientifically investigated as
a lot of the questions that we have
about dogs haven't but I would say that
I think there's suggestive evidence that
because of their diminutive size they
need some other thing which makes them
appear bigger or formidable or strong
and making a lot of noise is one of the
ways that animals always try to make
themselves seem stronger or more
formidable so that might be what little
dogs are trying to do but I loved when
people's you know get a little dog
thinking that it's just like I mean I
don't love it I hate when people get a
little dog being like just a toy it's
just easy to deal with and often they
have more energy are more rambunctious
and are louder than a large dog we have
this weird notion that little dogs are
gonna be toys and big dogs are hard to
deal with
large dogs sometimes they're mellower
and they don't spend all day yapping and
little dogs sometimes spend all day
lapping into running around like mad so
you know no dogs before you take one
into your house for the next 15 years
[Music]